I always had a passion for
understanding the Earth system.
So I always read
about it on my own.
When you watch the
Discovery Channel,
and you see people on these
big expeditions and stuff,
and you always
think that it almost
feels only like a dream to you.
She actually got
back just this summer
from deploying our floats
into the southern ocean
on a cruise between Sydney,
Australia and Papeete, Tahiti.
And I'll tell you, the float
was bigger than she was,
but she muscled it
into the water anyway.
Totally awesome.
I'm so proud of them,
I can't tell you.
It's been so rewarding to be
part of these big projects
studying our ocean and studying
our planet, that as a kid,
I used to just dream
about, in a sense,
of being part of those things.
And it's been really rewarding
working with a Joellen,
because with her
connections, she was
able to get me on that ship.
So having that
experience-- being
out on a boat for 46 days
in the middle of nowhere,
12 hours a day, through
sun, through storms,
through everything,
experiencing the ocean
and studying it--
it's just extremely
rewarding and exciting
to be a part of.